all right welcome back to new rock stars
i'm eric boss i am back in my hotel room
uh all the the drugs are off screen
here in anaheim for star wars
celebration there's no drugs there's no
drugs in here does this guy look like he
uses no i'd faint in this video i'm
going to give you a description of what
i just saw as far as the footage from
mandalorian season 3. it looks like it
was just a special thing just for people
who were there in hall a at the
lucasfilm studio showcase i can't wait
for this footage to be released online
because it looks awesome it's a full
trailer for mandalorian season three it
is coming to disney plus february of
2023. so while it's still brushing my
mind i'm just gonna try to like paint a
picture for you of what was there what's
gonna happen this next season and what
we can expect so the footage opens with
i believe you just hear the mandalorian
flute
and then i'm pretty sure there's a shot
of amanda just walking across the ruined
surface of mandalore wreckage everywhere
after the night of a thousand tears
which we saw in the book of boba fett
and that flashback as we saw these like
nuke size bombings across the the
surface of the planet this was the
incident that was described by moth
gideon he bombed the hell out of the
planet we hear the voice of the armorer
who's just really laying on the guilt
thick you removed your helmet you're
beyond redemption this comes after the
confession in that episode of the book
of effect when did jaron told the armor
and told paz visa that he took off his
helmet it looks like a big setting for
this season is going to be the planet of
mandalore we totally see footage of
mando walking through the mines of
mandalore to find those living waters
that being the one place that the
armorer told him that he could go to to
fully reclaim his mandalorian identity
there's also an incredible shot of just
catan sitting in a mandalorian throne
room or the throne room wherever she is
in exile while the home world is ruined
and the place looks stark bare abandoned
like what rule like what kingdom is she
really ruling over if most of the
mandalorian people are scattered in a
diaspora she looks pissed she's bitter
tensions are high between her and den
and she says your cult gave up on
mandalore long before the purge which
just gives us a sense of the
factionalism between the mandalorian
people and she's calling the watch what
it is it is a cult the fact that they
refuse to show their faces is genuinely
weird most mandalorians are totally okay
removing their helmets and i'm curious
to see more of this history of how the
death watch became the watch when things
really changed and if it truly was
before the 9000 tears what was that
dispute could maul have had something to
do with it the fact that we had members
of the death watch who were still
aligned with maul during that second
siege of mandalore that we saw in the
clone wars final season did the watch
and house visalus split away from bo
katan when she was trying to rule over
the different clans like what happened
after we last saw her in rebels when she
just raised the sword over the people
and they all claimed allegiance to her
but she was given that sword she didn't
win it is that something the watch threw
in her face and the watch might have
just been that one [ __ ] in the room
who constantly questioned her authority
and that bitterness that's now stuck
with her and it's fueling her anger at
din there is one great shot of just a
tree filled with the the kawakian the
salacious p crumb race those are the
monkey lizards and they actually do look
like monkey lizards now in this tree
they have these long tails they're just
kind of like giggling at you as we walk
underneath it and whereas before
selection speaker has always just been
like a cackling puppet now we actually
see them moving it's amazing how the
show is bringing to life and giving a
sense of texture and vitality to things
that were previously either cg or in the
animation or just like puppets i'm
amazed with the puppetry with grogu how
they're able to make it look like he is
walking independently in addition to
spending a lot of time on mandalore it
seemed like the footage showed mado
returning to navarro because we checked
back in with greek karga he's got uh
like these nice flowing red robes in
front of that one heroic statue of ig-11
memorializing his sacrifice at the end
of mandalorian season one that statue's
now in the town square that's where
they're hanging out now definitely
captain carson thibault returns no sight
of gina carano
not surprised pele moto shows back up so
we're going back to tatooine and her
junk shop there was also some shots of
dr pershing the uh the imperial
scientist would that passion looked like
it might have been related to the
community we know he's involved in this
plot to try to harvest blood and genetic
material from the child so i imagine
this season is going to be exploring
more of that whatever this plot may be
to clone jedi again i don't need too
much setup for the sequel trilogy i'd
love it if uh it could be setting up
something completely different the big
line we hear from did jaron in this
footage is he said he's going to
mandalore so he can be forgiven for his
transgressions that's gonna be his
mission to uh explore these living
waters and we'll we'll see what that
really is we see some shots of him going
into these caves into the mines of
mandalore and to be honest the footage
all looks really great the footage all
looks pretty done the music is
incredible it's tense it's spiritual
it's creepy we'll be getting some space
battles for sure and it ends with boca
time in her mandalorian night owl helmet
telling grosgu do you think your
father's the only mandalorian so one of
the best episodes of season two was when
mando met bocaton and her crew and we
got a sense of the wider culture of the
mandalorians there's so much to there's
so much to dig into there i can't wait
for this new season can't wait to break
it down the future of star wars is
bright uh i gotta get back to work with
some other stuff but be sure to uh check
out our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com we have a new
obi-wan inspired shirt it's our new
latest obsession it's really the best
way to support us you can follow me
adiavoss follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars on youtube and next up
will be our reactions to the first two
episodes of obi-wan kenobi and my
breakdown of the android trailers keep
an eye out for that on the channel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you